año 2001 retornaba de argentina con mi
familia después de haber vivido dos años
por allá y yo tenía siete años una
barriga de este tamaño
0 condición deportiva la verdad
no me gustaba el deporte no me gustaba
el fútbol no me gustaba absolutamente
nada y cuando inicie las clases en un
colegio prontito de las cuestiones que
más me llamó la atención fue lo
importante que era el fútbol y para
absolutamente todos no si no no jugaba
al fútbol en el recreo no tenía con
quién pasar no tenía con quién jugar era
difícil hacer relaciones en ese sentido
y yo les voy a ser muy honesto yo era
muy malo y no podía ni siquiera pegarle
a la pelota yo recuerdo inclusión no
recreos mis compañeros tienen una regla
el que le pegaba con la punta del zapato
tenía que salir 5 minutos de afuera de
la cancha porque no era bien visto
imagínese el recreo duraba 30 minutos o
sea yo podía tocar la pelota cinco veces
por recreo no era lo que se me permitía
no más que eso éste a partir de eso
decidí empezar a practicar algún deporte
inicie con el karate que tampoco era muy
bueno pero dentro de lo que había era lo
que mejor podría hacer inicie con el
karate y recuerdo un día cuando fui al
entrenamiento del profesor había faltado
por alguna
y yo estaba en el colegio no tenía nada
que hacer empieza a dar vueltas por el
colegio hasta que mi madre venga a
recoger y recuerdo que viene a cancha de
fútbol que mis compañeros estaban
entrenando
después de haberlos observado durante
10-15 minutos
me atrevió acercando en el entrenador
mauricio garcía y le pedí permiso para
que podía ingresar al entrenamiento por
alguna extraña razón ese día mauricio la
verdad que se portó muy bien conmigo me
puso mucha atención pese a que yo no era
ni siquiera parte del grupo y él estuvo
conmigo durante todo el entrenamiento
tratando enseñarme a ayudarme a mejorar
si bien no le podía pegar la pelota
entiendo un día no se cambia
absolutamente nada yo salí ese día del
entrenamiento y lo único que quería
hacer era jugar al fútbol otra vez
llegué a la casa
y le pedimos le comenté que iba a
cambiar de actividad no iba a ser más
kárate y que quería dedicarme al fútbol
desde ese día
empezó un camino totalmente distinto
para mí el fútbol se convirtió en mi
vida yo lo único que hacía era ver
fútbol hablar de fútbol respirar el
fútbol jugaba en todos los recreos me
quedaba todos los del colegio llegaba
del colegio a la casa al patio de nuevo
a patear la pelota porque era lo que me
apasionaba y era lo único que quería
hacer
empecé a mejorar mucho se empezó a
mejorar muchas razones obvias por una
cuestión de práctica practicaba el doble
o el triple que el resto
y a los 11 años fui donde mi papá y le
pedí que quería ser futbolista
profesional era mi sueño creo que muchos
chicos sueñan con eso recuerdo fui a las
pruebas del equipo deportivo quito en
ese momento existente de por hoy casi
desaparecido durante siete días hicimos
pruebas incesantes donde pasaron más de
150 200 chicos y luego de siete días
dieron la lista final de los jugadores
que iban a permanecer en el equipo y
dieron mi nombre seguramente uno de los
mejores días de mi vida el pase de no
poder patear una pelota a ser parte de
un equipo si vienen categorías
formativas para un equipo profesional
desde ese día yo empecé con el camino ya
han rumbo hacia el fútbol profesional
como les digo el deseo que yo tenía de
jugar fútbol
tremendo
yo estaba dispuesto a dejar
absolutamente todo por alcanzar ese
sueño
en ese transcurso de los 12 a los 18
años
si fui parte de las formativas deportivo
quito tuve la suerte de participar en la
selección ecuatoriana de fútbol sub-15
sub-17 selecciones de pichincha las
cosas se empezaron a dar muy bien yo
firmé mi primer contrato profesional
como jugador a los 15 años
algo que yo nunca me hubiese imaginado
cuando cuando era chiquito no
pero también tuve que sacrificar un
montón de cuestiones a partir de este
tema del fútbol
y esta es la parte que yo creo que es
muy importante porque muchos no
entienden todo el camino que uno tiene
que recorrer para poder llegar a esos
puntos
y yo de los 12 a los 18 por ejemplo
nunca supe lo que era un viernes por
ejemplo salir del colegio con mis amigos
salir a una fiesta quedarme esta tarde
yo recuerdo importarme recoger las 10 de
la noche de las fiestas vásquez en saná
a las 9 me quedaba una hora y una hora
porque yo los días sábados tenía que
estar a las 7 de la mañana de pie listo
para jugar un partido de fútbol y claro
yo cuando juega al fútbol más allá de
hacerlo por diversión
me estaba jugando también una carrera
entonces tenía que tener el mayor
profesionalismo posible y el mayor
profesionalismo posible a los 18 años 17
pronto negro de un año antes 17 años me
gradué de manera milagrosa porque yo iba
al colegio 22 horas al día más o menos
ya sexto curso del colegio conmigo se
portó muy bien no entiendo hasta el día
de hoy como logré graduarme si la verdad
que fue un milagro
tomé la decisión de irme a manta si
llegó la posibilidad de irme a jugar un
equipo allá del deportivo quito en ese
momento equipo estaba muy mal
económicamente el creo que estaba
quebrado y tenía que buscar otras
opciones y aprecio esta opción en mante
entonces al 17 años tomé la decisión de
irme a vivir a manta
y mis padres en eso la verdad que me
apoyaron muchísimo recuerdo que la
primera semana que llegué a manta no
había tenido tiempo de conseguir
departamento ni mucho menos mi padre
tenía un amigo allá de una situación
económica muy buena
y claro y esperaba llegar a un lindo
departamento algo estilo y recuerdo
llegar sin problemas a un departamento
donde yo tenía que convivir en un cuarto
con un pastor alemán de este tamaño que
no lo conocía no tenía aire
acondicionado 30 grados el excusado sin
tapa o sea era un desastre y durante 78
días yo tuve que vivir en esas
condiciones porque cuando tenía que
probarme en el equipo y no sabía si iba
a quedarme o no después de los 7 días
recibí la buena noticia que pude
quedarme y obviamente mis papás me
ayudaron a mejorar un poco las funciones
de vida buscamos un departamento y todo
fue mucho mejor la adaptación en eso la
adaptación me ayudó muchísimo yo no
sabía cocinar absolutamente nada
recuerdo mi mamá
viajaba cada 2-3 meses a manta me dejaba
carnes congeladas a para nada de una
refrigeradora para que yo pudiese comer
durante durante 23 meses porque claro no
tenía idea de cómo llegué a prepararlos
pero bueno la verdad que fue una etapa
en mi vida muy linda tuve muy buenos
meses en el mante y a partir de eso por
buenas participaciones mías de los
partidos barcelona me ficha si yo viajó
a guayaquil en guayaquil estoy durante
un año y medio tuve la oportunidad de
compartir el camerino y cancha con con
jugadores de selección canciones del
ecuador en el año 2012 de berna muy
linda experiencia pero lastimosamente en
barcelona era muy difícil jugar no era
un equipo muy grande yo jugadores con
mucho prestigio que también tenían
mejores condiciones que yo inclusive y
no pude tener los minutos que yo quería
ya estaba en una edad ya 19 20 años
donde yo ya tenía que estar jugando en
primera división y yo seguía jugando en
reserva y por eso tomé la decisión de
retornar a mante una vez que retornó yo
a manta y seguramente tuve el año y me
el mejor año y medio de que
deportivamente hablando donde tuve mucha
participación reserva fue importante
estuve en el equipo de primera
y en el año 2014 el manta pierde la
categoría descendemos con independiente
del valle última fecha cada y perdemos
la categoría bajamos a la serie b eso
para los que por ahí no están muy
metidos en el mundo del fútbol significa
reducción de presupuestos un montón de
problemas como institución
pero pese a eso me habían ofrecido un
contrato me habían ofreció un contrato y
yo estaba contento y manta
decidí tomarlo salí en diciembre en
vacaciones y más o menos en febrero
cuando es el inicio de temporada retorne
a manta el día que yo retornó me
encuentro con una gran sorpresa de qué
la directiva de los presidentes de
habían renunciado y había habido un
cambio general en el club y ese contrato
que a mí se me había ofrecido ya no
existía
y se transforma en un contrato ridículo
o ser imposible aceptarlo yo no podía
tomarlo pero yo había dejado pasar dos
meses de enero y febrero muy importantes
para el tema de buscar equipos y
lastimosamente me quedé sin equipo y me
quedé sin equipo con 21 años muchas
partes en reserva en primera en una
situación muy complicada y no le
obviamente yo estaba muy desgastado ya
es una profesión que te genera mucho
desgaste desde lo mental desde lo físico
yo tuve que pasar navidades yéndome a
probar en otros equipos porque porque
así funcionaba a diciembre del mes donde
donde tienes que conseguir el trabajo
entonces fue cuando tomé seguramente la
decisión más difícil de mi vida que fue
dejar el fútbol
estoy recuerdo entre a la oficina con mi
papá
que haya llanto destruido y le dije no
comas
tomamos esa decisión y bueno tenía que
encontrar algún plan ese momento
para ver cómo resolver esa situación y
era un chico que negro de con las cosas
del colegio nunca fui a la universidad
ellos siempre le hice a distancia cero
experiencia laboral lo único que yo
había hecho en mi vida era patear una
pelota
eso es lo que yo había hecho
[Música]
y obviamente no lo que me apasionaba lo
hice desde los 8 años hasta el día de
hoy lo sigo haciendo y tomé la decisión
de
empezará a prepararme para ser
entrenador de fútbol
y entrenador de fútbol
luego de más o menos un año de formación
decidió iniciar mi propio negocio en
conjunto con otros socios que conocí tan
en el fútbol ex jugadores y entrenadores
y conformamos una academia un centro de
formación donde nosotros podríamos
ayudar hoy o todavía sea la oportunidad
de ayudar a chicos con mi situación que
de chicos les cueste o tengan problemas
sociales justamente a través de por no
poder jugar bien al fútbol puedes darles
una mano enseñarles que mejoren que
crezcan que tengan una mejor transición
en el colegio y para aquellos que
quieran ser profesionales también
ayudarles a través de la experiencia lo
que yo había vivido que ellos entiendan
cómo es el camino y qué es lo que yo
hice mal y ayudarles de ellos para que
no cometan los mismos errores y para no
hacerles muy largo a la historia llevo
cuatro años con el centro de formación
educamos ganados de 1300 chicos somos de
ciento de formación más grande de todo
el país y es un éxito rotundo es un
éxito rotundo y sigue en crecimiento
y hace aproximadamente seis siete meses
yo estaba en el complejo entrenamiento y
llegó un hombre en una moto y me entrego
me entregó un sobre y yo cuando abrí el
sobre dentro del sobre había un carnet y
un carnet o una identificación que se
usaba cuando cuando uno jugaba fútbol
sin este carnet era cuando yo tenía ocho
años en una liga barrial que se llamaba
chaupicruz
y era cuando yo era dirigido por
mauricio garcía el entrador que les
comenté al inicio de la charla
mauricio falleció más de los 18 meses y
este es uno de los amigos de mauricio
que ayuda a hacer la limpieza de la casa
y dentro del velador de mauricio él
encontró este carnet lo único que había
dentro del velador en este camión que
debía tener 14 años de antigüedad y que
mauricio lo había conservado durante
toda su vida
ese rato la verdad les digo yo me puse
muy mal para mí fue fue golpeado y me
golpeó bastante y me puse a pensar
en todo lo que yo estaba haciendo yo
tenía la oportunidad de ser el mauricio
garcía para muchos chicos y darles una
mano
cambiarles la vida mejorar las que ellos
pudieran inclusive que inclusive tener
esa transición del colegio que para
muchos es muy complicada parece que no
pero es muy complicada por no tener
estas condiciones deportivas
y me di cuenta que el mayor de mis
fracasos que había sido para el niño
haber sido un futbolista profesional se
había terminado convirtiendo en el mayor
de mis éxitos
todos esos años que yo viví en todos los
años de sacrificios yo les digo tampoco
a la universidad no saben yo la
curiosidad que tengo de de saber que es
una clase universitaria es que no sé de
saber lo que es una fiesta de
universidad tampoco lo sé de irme al
exterior y vivir dos o tres años de una
universidad fuera conocer otra gente me
mata la curiosidad y estoy un poquito
viejo no creo que te alcance pero pero
tengo esa curiosidad y todo eso a mí me
marcó mucho y me marcó mucho porque para
mí había sido un gran fracaso y hoy por
hoy me doy cuenta que todo eso que yo
viví fue necesario para hoy poder ayudar
a tantos chicos a que cambien su vida a
que mejoren a que sean aceptados
socialmente
les agradezco